[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter
ginny weasley love potions and a popular
harry potter fan theory
that combines the three first things
first i can't take credit for the theory
as the theory in question has been
floating around the internet for many
many years
what i want to do however is relay this
interesting theory to you all
give you my take and then see what you
have to say
the theory put quite succinctly is this
ginny weasley
gave harry potter a love potion the
theory
also suggests that harry and ginny end
up together for that reason
and for that reason alone there are a
few reasonably credible arguments for
why this could in fact be the case
most of which i have rebuttals too but
let's dive into how and why
this theory could work first one of the
main bases for the theory
is that harry seemingly fell for ginny
quite suddenly up until the point at
which they fell in love
they weren't particularly close nor were
there any direct indicators that they
would or
should end up together one moment
harry's with cho chang
in another moment film harry is flirting
on the waitress at sweets cafe
and the next minute he's married to
ginny with babies so
how could harry have become so quickly
infatuated with ginny
the answer a love potion the main
supporting argument for this theory is
that love potions have been historically
used by the weasley clan
maybe not for this purpose but used in
jest and in other less serious
circumstances the bottom line is that
love potions have been used by them
and they certainly know how to make them
ginny's own mother molly admitted to
using them in her youth
and fred and george sold them so their
perspective on these types of potions
can hardly be too severe the love potion
in question
is called amortentia a powerful love
potion that causes extreme infatuation
or obsession from the drinker and
mortensia is the most powerful love
potion in the world
it is distinctive for its
mother-of-pearl sheen and steam rises
from the potion
and spirals amortensia smells different
to each person
according to what attracts them while
inducing friendship
can be a powerful way to change
allegiances inducing love is even more
powerful
amortentia is considered by some to be
the most dangerous potion of all
as it doesn't even induce actual love
just a semblance of love
that is derived from strong obsession we
see
and hear of ammotensia in the harry
potter franchise quite a bit
and it can make people do some very
uncharacteristically strange things
one of the most famous examples of a
love potion being used
is in the story of the birth of
voldemort where murapi
voldemort's mother infamously used a
love potion on his father
allegedly this is the basis for
voldemort being evil
as because he was conceived without love
he would have never had any capacity to
understand
or feel love in fact the prevalence of
love potions or potions in general for
that matter in the half-blood prince
is one of the other arguments supporting
the theory allegedly
this is the book in which ginny takes
action and finally gives harry the
potion
it also sort of makes sense because it's
in this book that potions are popping up
more than ever why wouldn't ginny who
had a crush on harry
take advantage of amortensia the general
thematic surrounding potions
is introduced almost immediately when
slughorn is headhunted by dumbledore
to come and teach potions at the school
not only that but there's a large focus
on slughorn's potions lessons
something that hadn't been focused on
much in the books prior
we're introduced to a whole new world of
potions and potions materials
felix felicis dittony bazaars and
most importantly the love potion
amortentia
and all of a sudden love potions become
a major plot point
meripe used a love potion on tom riddle
senior the reason for voldemort's
inability to feel love
fred and george who recently opened up
their shop are selling the stuff
and ramil devane even hit ron with one
even if
it was meant for harry so was rolling
trying to hint at something here
or is this all just one massive
coincidence i mean it all checks out
ginny and harry certainly have a
blossoming relationship
in the wake of the introduction of love
potions but
is it true here's what i think here's
the main problem with this theory
ginny and harry had a lot more chemistry
than a lot of people think
and this is largely due to the film's
poor representation
of the nuances of their relationship i
think that if we go by the films and the
films alone
then this theory checks out more but the
books tell a different story
you see their relationship is much more
complex than the film's depict
in the books harry suppresses his
feelings for ginny over a long period of
time
and the film's critical error here is
that they made it seem like this was
some sudden
new thing with an immediate onset to the
casual observer or someone that has only
seen the films
harry and ginny's relationship comes out
of nowhere failure to develop ginny's
character inhibited their ability to
develop her relationship with harry
in the films we see jenny dating other
guys in an attempt to get over harry
but once again without the context of
the books it wouldn't necessarily appear
that way
it would just look like ginny dating we
also see harry forming romantic
relationships with people like cho chang
and even the waitress from sweet's cafe
with absolutely no regard for ginny
in my opinion this was one of the film's
biggest faults and i say film explicitly
here because this was not a mistake made
by the books
i love the films but their approach to
harry and ginny's relationship
was just very sudden and forced almost
as if
a love potion would have been the only
way to actually make it happen
another reason that love potion theory
doesn't check out is that harry isn't
exhibiting the obsessive behavior
alluded to in other situations in which
the potion is used
tom riddle senior who previously had
absolutely zero interest in meripee
became so obsessive that he dropped
everything else in his life
and had her child with her acting
against all of the prior stigma that he
had held toward therapy and her family
even the brief segway into ron's
obsession with romel devane
tells us that amortensia doesn't just
produce light feelings of love
it creates a burning obsession an
infatuation which is why the potion is
truly so dangerous
those under the effects of the potion
exhibit a loss of inhibitions
a lack of regard for every other aspect
of their life and harry
still fighting against voldemort and out
hunting horcruxes
never displayed this type of tunnel
vision him and ginny still got together
but it was passive ginny wasn't the only
thing going on in harry's life
and he certainly never gave her his
undivided attention
furthermore if ginny knowingly gave
harry a love potion fully aware of its
powerful effects
she would have been knowingly
jeopardizing the entire wizarding world
the last reason that i'm not convinced
by this theory is that love is a
powerful and central theme across the
entire harry potter story
and this theory would put a glaring hole
in the thematic that rowling was trying
to establish
we're hit with a notion that love is the
most powerful form of magic
right from the beginning when harry is
saved by his mother's loving sacrifice
and later we're told that voldemort the
primary dark force working against harry
is the way that he is because of his
inability to understand love
rowling purposely contrasts real love
with infatuation
because she wants the reader to
understand the differences with real
love always ending up on top
to have harry the main protagonist whose
very life was saved by love
end up in a relationship as a result of
a love potion would be a great
disservice to the story
as a whole also i just don't think the
ginny would do it
what do you guys think i'd love to hear
your opinion on this theory
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time do not pity the dead
harry
pity the living and above all those who
live without love
[Music]
you